TO THE LETTER?
KEEP IN MIND, THE SLIGHTEST
MISTAKE WOULD MEAN PRISON TIME.
WOULD THAT BE JUST AS?
OR WOULD IT BE ITS OPPOSITE?
JEROME CORSI WOULD KNOW FIRST
HAND AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
MR. CORSI, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
>> MY PLEASURE, TUCKER,
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT UNDER
OATH, SO OUR VIEWERS WILL HAVE
TO ASSESS THE ACCURACY OF WHAT
YOU SAY.
BUT BEFORE WE GET TO YOUR
INTERACTIONS WITH THE CORSI
INVESTIGATION, JUST THE BASICS.
HAVE YOU EVER HAVE CONTACT WITH
JULIAN ASSANGE?
>> NO, I'VE NEVER MET
JULIAN ASSANGE, NEVER SPOKEN
WITH HIM, NEVER EMAILED HIM.
I'VE HAD NO CONTACT WITH
JULIAN ASSANGE WHATSOEVER.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU EVER HAD
CONTACT WITH RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE OR SUBVERTED --
KNOWINGLY SUBVERTED, THE
INTEREST OF YOUR OWN COUNTRY?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I'VE BEEN A LOYAL AMERICAN, I
HAD NO CONTACTS WITH RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE, I HAVE NO BUSINESS
INTEREST IN RUSSIA, I HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH RUSSIA.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN TO RUSSIA.
>> Tucker: SO TELL ME IF I
SUMMARIZED WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU
ACCURATELY.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
GETS A HOLD OF YOUR PERSONAL
COMPUTER AND YOUR PHONE.
THEY'VE GOT ALL THE RECORDS, ALL
THE DATA, AND MAY START ASKING
YOU ABOUT THINGS THEY ALREADY
KNOW, AND MAY ASK YOU, HAVE
YOU EVER TRY TO BROKER A MEETING
WITH ASSANGE?
YOU NOT REMEMBER FORWARDING THIS
EMAIL, THEY COME BACK AND SAY,
BINGO, YOU JUST COMMITTED A
FELONY.
IF THAT WOULD HAPPEN?
>> IT'S EVEN WORSE.
FIRST OF ALL, I OFFERED -- I
GAVE MY COMPUTER FOR THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, I GAVE THEM MY
CELL PHONE.
I GAVE THEM ALL OF MY EMAIL
ACCOUNTS.
I GAVE THEM EVERYTHING THEY
WANTED, MY TWITTER ACCOUNTS, I
SIGNED PERMISSION AND HANDED ALL
THIS OVER.
NOW ON THE FIRST DAY WHEN I WAS
INTERVIEWED, I DIDN'T REMEMBER
THAT EMAIL.
NOW THE SPECIAL COUNSEL CAME IN
AND BLEW UP AND THEY ACTUALLY
SENT ME HOME AND GAVE ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
EMAILS.
WHEN I CAME BACK, I AMENDED THE
TESTIMONY TO SAY THAT I NOW
REMEMBER THE EMAIL.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WAS HAPPY
WITH THAT UNTIL I COULDN'T GIVE
THEM WHAT THEY WANTED.
WHICH WAS A CONNECTION THAT I
HAD WITH ASSANGE, WHICH THEY
ASSUMED I HAVE COME WHICH I I
DIDN'T HAVE.
NOW SUDDENLY, THEY FORGOT THEY
ALLOWED ME TO AMEND MY TESTIMONY
AND THEY ARE GOING BACK TO THE
MISTAKE I MADE, WHEN I FORGOT
THE EMAILS.
SO REALLY, I THINK, IT IS
COMPLETELY FRAUDULENT, THE
CHARGE THAT THEY WERE TRYING TO
GET ME TO PLEAD TO.
I REFUSED TO PLEAD TO    TO A LV
I REFUSED TO PLEAD TO    TO A L.
>> Tucker: I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED HERE.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU
HELD -- WITHHELD FROM THEM?
YOU SAID YOU GIVE THEM ACCESS TO
EVERYTHING.
IF YOU HAD DIRECT CONTACT WITH
JULIAN ASSANGE, OR WITH SOMEONE
ELSE OUT CONTACT WITH ASSANGE,
THEY WOULD ALREADY KNOW THAT,
WOULDN'T THEY?
>> I WOULD THINK SO.
I GAVE THEM EVERYTHING
VOLUNTARILY.
I HAVE A TIME MACHINE ON MY
COMPUTER, WHICH RECORDED
EVERYTHING PRECISELY AND KEPT IT
IN THE TIME MACHINE, BACKER
2015.
THEY COMPUTER BROKE IN 2018 BUT
I GAVE IT, I KEPT IT -- I
VOLUNTARILY GAVE THEM THE
17-INCH APPLE LAPTOP AND THE
TIME MACHINE.
I GAVE THEM MY CELL PHONE.
I SIGNED OVER PERMISSION FOR ALL
OF MY EMAILS, GAVE THEM THE
USERNAMES AND PASSWORDS.
I ALLOWED THEM TO SEE MY
TWITTER, AND EVEN HELPED WANT TO
GO DOWNLOAD MY TWITTER AND MY
GOOGLE ACCOUNT.
I SENT OVER VERIZON ACCOUNTS.
EVERYTHING THEY WANTED, I HAD
NOTHING TO HIDE.
I GAVE IT TO THEM IMMEDIATELY.
FOR HAVING FORGOTTEN THE ONE
BECAUSE I HAD NOT REVIEWED THE
EMAIL, THIS PARTICULAR EMAIL, I
AM NOW BEING CHARGED WITH
WILLFULLY AND KNOWINGLY GIVING
FALSE INFORMATION, WHICH IS
NONSENSE.
I NEVER WILLINGLY AND FALSELY
GAVE FALSE INFORMATION.
I INTENDED ALWAYS TO TELL THE
TRUTH.
MY MEMORY WAS NOT PERFECT.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
LET ME JUST TO SAY, IF YOU
DELETED EMAILS, PRESUMABLY, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO RETRIEVE THOSE
EMAILS.
SO THEY WOULD KNOW, I THINK,
WHAT YOUR COMMUNICATIONS WERE.
I HAVE READ ACCOUNTS IN THE
PRESS, I READ RUN IN THE
WASHINGTON MONTHLY, A LIBERAL
MAGAZINE, SAYING THAT YOU
DESERVE TO GO TO PRISON BECAUSE
YOU HAVE EXPRESSED VIEWS THAT
THEY DON'T LIKE.
DO YOU THINK THAT YOUR POLITICAL
VIEWS ARE PLAYING A ROLE IN THE
DECISION OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
TO CHARGE YOU WITH A FELONY?
>> YES, I THINK -- ALSO, BY THE
WAY, THEY ACCUSED ME OF DELETING
EMAILS AND I TOLD THEM THEY
RESTORED THE EMAILS.
I SUPPOSEDLY DELETED THROUGH THE
TIME MACHINE.
THIS IS A POLITICAL WITCH HUNT.
BECAUSE I DID NOT HAVE A CONTACT
WITH ASSANGE, BUT YET HAD
FIGURED OUT THAT ASSANGE HAD
PROGRESSED AS EMAILS, I FIGURED
IT OUT AND TOLD ROGER STONE AND
TOLD MANY PEOPLE IN AUGUST,
AND IT JUST HAPPENED THAT I WAS
RIGHT.
THE PROSECUTOR SAID THAT WE WILL
NOT BELIEVE IN YOUR 25TH WEDDING
ANNIVERSARY TO ITALY WITH YOUR
LIFE AND FAMILY, YOU HAD DIVINE
INSPIRATION AND GOD TOLD YOU
PODESTA HAD ASSANGE'S EMAILS.
I I DON'T KNOW IF I WANT TO PUTI
I I DON'T KNOW IF I WANT TO PUTT
OUT CRASSLY BUT I DID FIGURED
OUT AND I CORRECTED THE DOTS,
AND YOU JUST WANT BELIEVE I
FIGURED IT OUT.
>> Tucker: QUICKLY, BECAUSE I
CAN'T RESIST ASKING BECAUSE I
THINK THE HUMAN COST IS WORTH
KNOWING ABOUT, WHAT DOES THIS
CAUSE DO?
>> IT IS GOING TO BE JUST TO GET
STARTED A COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
I MEAN, IT BANKED UP HERE VERY
QUICKLY.
AND THE SPECIAL PROSECUTORS BLOW
YOU UP, THEY DO THIS WHAT I CALL
PERJURY TRAP, IT IS REALLY --
THEY ASK YOU A QUESTION, THEY
HAVE MATERIAL THEY WANT TO SHOW
YOU, YOU HAVE FORGOTTEN ABOUT
IT, THEY SAY, YOU JUST COLLIDE
BECAUSE THIS EMAIL YOU FORGOT
ABOUT IN 2016 PROVES YOUR
CURRENT MEMORY IS WRONG.
IT'S A MEMORY TEST.
THEY MAY ACCUSE YOU OF LYING.
IT'S COMPLETELY RIGGED AND IT'S
POLITICALLY-DRIVEN BY CLINTON
OPERATIVES WHO HAVE AN AGENDA.
IF YOU CAN GIVE THEM -- ROGER IS
RIGHT -- IF YOU CAN'T GIVE THEM
WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING FOR TO
FILL THEIR NARRATIVE, THEY BLOW
YOU UP AND CHARGE YOU WITH A
CRIME.